[Music]
ten years ago
the eu ratified united nations
convention on the rights of persons with
disabilities
it reaffirms that persons with
disabilities are
entitled to their human rights and
fundamental freedoms
the eu worked to ensure that all our
actions
are fully inclusive of persons with
disabilities
while promoting a europe without
obstacles for this to happen
member states must also always apply the
convention
and eu rules when designing national
policies
our work brought real improvement on
accessible products and services
transport education and training social
protection
health and more needs to happen to
ensure
a union of equality structural
discrimination
keeps millions of europeans with
disabilities
on the margins of our societies the
covet 19 pandemic has highlighted
these inequalities in the coming weeks
i will present a new and strengthened
strategy on the rights of persons with
disabilities
for 2021 2030 it will
turn the rights enshrined in the
convention
into action and provide a strong
framework
to ensure that no one is left behind
and i will continue to work in dialogue
and partnership with persons with
disabilities
our ambitions are high and they will
require
everyone's commitment i am committed to
building
a union of equality we are stronger
together
as diverse societies we are stronger
when all our citizens are valued and
included
together this is our responsibility to
ensure that persons with disabilities
can participate equally in all areas of
life
[Music]
you